[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to an
always late but still on time episode of
honest trailer commentary four
nope uh we had some technical
difficulties last week weren't able to
shoot this live in the studio and we
weren't gonna just zoom from home no no
we were gonna wait until we were back in
the office next week
then just do it before the other one so
uh right after this we will not have a
costume change at least i didn't bring
one and we'll roll right into thor four
but uh now let's talk about nope um a
film that i saw
now like three four weeks ago and
remember enjoy i vaguely recall nope it
was pretty good i think right yeah i
liked it a lot uh and i will say that uh
plenty of moments from this film stuck
with me explicitly the people being
digested by the big alien butthole in
the sky that represents hollywood yes uh
the the chimpanzee beating the sitcom
cast to death um i remember that and a
shoe there was a shoe involved there was
a shoe stick sticking up yeah um
that's all from nope that's that's all
folks nailed it no i really liked it i
think that um this one and we can get
into it uh
was maybe thematically and like
overarching metaphor wise less
interesting to me than get out and us
but i think is a visual storyteller
jordan peele is just like
has reached and
is maintaining the level of excellence
that he began in those two films yeah
the fact that so many of those night
shots were shot during the day and then
like they made them look like they were
at night is amazing it's beautifully
shot and i like that
i always like when someone goes oh this
is what you think i am so now i'm going
to pivot and no this is just straight up
an alien butthole movie yeah that is
what this is like i know that you're
looking for it to be like i don't
understand it blah blah blah obviously
he's always going to have like these
huge thematic um
themes
but so obviously that's always going to
be part of his work but
far less being like what did i just see
than us and more like hey no this is a
pretty straightforward
alien movie
um starring
two very charming actors playing the
worst people you've ever met
i wouldn't go that far oh yeah
i mean worst is in like i mean they're
not like serial killers but
if you met them in your real life that
whole day would be like this [ __ ]
just ruined my day yeah i mean we can
discuss i think that there it's in a
deleted scene that we cut but it's like
by horror movie rules
don't one or both of them deserve to die
yes
by horror movie rules like if you're a
jerk uh or if you like uh you know
refuse to learn the lesson that the
butthole's trying to teach you you
usually uh get eaten so lon what's your
overall take no i love this one i think
it's my favorite jordan peel i feel like
i feel like with everyone he like get
out is so like he's got this sort of
high concept this really kind of
interesting take on a way to do a horror
movie that's really sort of about like a
social commentary thing that he wants to
discuss and then i think you have us
which is more of like in between like
there's there's commentary there's stuff
going on but it's also just like a lot
of horror tropes he wanted to experiment
with and now i think nope is the first
time it feels like this is just a jordan
peel
movie like it's it's ideas it's horror
it's other things he likes it's just it
feels like it's very much its own thing
and it's hard to really compare it to
any one other movie like there's
elements of a lot of different movies
yes but it doesn't feel like oh this is
jordan peele's take on an x or a y or
this is him doing of this or even then
you know p before it came out people
were like oh this is going to be jordan
peel's alien movie right and it is but
it feels a lot more specific than
just that it's not just his take on an
alien invasion movie it's it's his take
on like kitsch culture and it's his take
on yeah like hollywood and the the movie
industry and the history of the
hollywood industry and how below the
line people versus above the line people
are are treated and looked at and also
like the way that now instead of helping
people when like a fight happens we're
all just like world right and taking out
like our videos and about you know
comparing the way that some people
people on film sets are treated and you
know the sort of animal actors and that
and all of that stuff together it's not
about any one of them it's about all of
them together and it feels like like a
cohesive whole in a way that i don't
know if the others do he's really he's
really advancing i think rapidly as a
yeah pretty incredible and that's why we
put him in some uh uh some high flute
and company uh as we do in this honest
trailer let's watch it
the following trailer is rated as for
spoilers
[Music]
in an entertainment landscape dominated
by
me three filmmakers are fighting to keep
cinema alive
spielberg
tarantino
and no one
but now with just his third film one
more name joins that hallowed list
the carpetron
marriott and the carpentrong duke marion
legendary sketch legendary sketch go
watch it yeah um i mean there's a
question already of like was there any
debate uh no because uh well danielle i
think you suggested la carpetron or was
it long yeah
so the carpet is my favorite i've
already been through and decided
i want him to keep making films and
we're just going to move through the
names you know one by one he will never
be
it will never run out because there's so
many good ones key and peel sort of
adopted hingle mcringleberry they
brought him back a few times
specifically so i feel like that's out
because he became a regular character
yeah so you got to pick from the rest of
them there's x-wing at aliciousness is
also very funny that's why my favorite
that's the the close a close one and
then there's some that are not easy to
pronounce like the constructions
so that's where anytime i do a joke
where it's just schwarzenegger noises
like that's where that's so of all the
pronounceable ones i think le carpet
it's that's poetry i mean that's like
that's the greatest fake name ever
really no i was trying to think of who
else belongs on that mount rushmore and
let's say that there's more than room
for more than four of people who are i'm
thinking like directors who can open a
movie just based on the director's name
people will go see it in in this day and
age i think it is spielberg nolan
tarantino and jordan peele
maybe denis villeneuve but maybe yeah
outside of dune
dude was his biggest one for sure
it's more niche villa
like he's still got fans but yeah like
it's a little
i don't know man i mean you get into
like obviously indie filmmakers like
people go see right there's like you
know there's the
chloe but like we're not she's not
opening films that would like the way
christopher nolan is yeah at that level
i think we're at four i mean we just
have i want more
and and internationally people still see
movies overseas with uh well i would say
there's also there's like in-betweeners
where they're like they still have name
recognition but we're just not sure like
it's like a sam mendes or a cheyenne
land no one's in in
no one in america so the new san mendes
just dropped let's go see the new mendez
there it is there's one coming out it's
getting oscars with olivia coleman
like i'm talking like a blockbuster like
there are people lined up to see the new
sam mendez movie i mean that aren't like
film freaks
like there are still there are still
directors with a lot of name recognition
they're in this kind of in-between zone
where
their movies still come out and there's
a certain amount of like fanfare too
like even david gray the guy did like ad
astra he's got a new one oh my god you
are so uh twitter film twitter brain
poison do you think people are lining up
for the news i'm saying they're had
asteroids i'm not saying you're lining
up
you're purposely considering what i'm
saying i'm saying that i'm saying that
there's there's this gray area below
that but i don't think there's many
people escaping that grey area to get
into the top
i think it's more black and white i
think it used to be more there was more
movement and now it's sort of stratified
yeah i think it's more like tv i think
that when you think of people where
you're i'm going to go see that like i
want to tune in for this television show
because i'm interested in seeing this
show runner
like that's a tv yeah i think yeah yeah
i'm just saying it's grim it's either
way it's great you want more it's that
even like the higher
like peter jackson's a guy who still got
a tremendous amount of name recognition
but i don't know is there an elf in it
not going right but like like lovely
bones is not you know topping people's
must-see list yeah um so there you go
let us know who we're uh who are missing
out on or please do i would love to know
who we're missing out on let us know who
wha
the next san mendes project you're
excited for
all right
one oscars and stuff he's acting like
he's like obscure settle up for an
old-fashioned black cowboy ufo movie
about black cowboys making ufo movies
the old-fashioned way that pulls triple
duty as an action adventure
sci-fi
horror and salute to analog filmmaking
no electricity on top of peel's
trademark social commentary on how
working in hollywood is like being
slowly digested by a giant butthole in
the sky
that tracks
daniel kaluya
um
a joke that is stupid because i realize
now that it's a audio-visual medium and
not the written word is uh i wrote that
tracts
digestive tract but they're realizing
you can't really tell that's just saying
that tracks even though not really
because they're in the tract of the
whatever keep playing
the other black oj who owns a white
bronco he's a horse trainer who'd rather
talk to animals than people
and talks to people like their animals
whoa his sister emerald is your classic
cloud chaser i direct write produce act
i do a little swinging on the side and
cloud chaser
who hatches a plan to chase a cloud for
cloud she may seem annoying and he may
seem like the oldest young man alive
but under the surface they're well
they're still both kind of dicks i can
monitor the feed remotely myself if you
want free of charge hell no
um
they're dicks uh
i find it hard to avoid the the the
auteur
self-insert when i'm thinking about oj
and jordan peel like is this jordan
peels
is he putting himself in that position
and being like i'm trying to
basically wrangle hollywood and like do
it my own way without getting absorbed
and eaten and i saw this as like him
kind of struggling with those ideas on
his own of like i want to keep my
integrity i want to like make money or
like enough money to keep this thing
going but i don't want to get swallowed
up by it so i can't look it in the eye i
just have to like focus on my work and
just like keep my head down and do my
thing it's so funny because we were
actually um me and uh uh lawn will uh i
don't drive i take buses and stuff so
lon is a sweetheart and will pick me up
uh for work sometimes and um we were
talking today about like um
boots riley and how it is very evident
that he wants nothing to do with the
system and he wants to do it all on his
own but that also obviously comes with
um
pitfalls and it comes with like um
you know there's pluses and there's
minuses and so i do think that's a very
interesting read on something like this
because there are people who are very
much like i want to do it my way but i
have to find a way to do that and like
pay my bills um
i got a baby uh with with gina from
from brooklyn 99 like i got to figure
some stuff out you know so
yeah that is a really interesting read
on that because we were literally just
talking about that thing of like you you
want to make your own art and you want
to make it your way and you don't
necessarily want to get super big
hollywood with it
and at a certain point you have to be
like there are concessions i am going to
have to make but how do i make those
without
like having my soul sucked up into the
big sky butthole yeah yeah i mean that's
how i was watching it was that this was
the predator was hollywood or audiences
you can kind of blend the two chasing
jordan peel around trying to trying to
suck him up like this is my territory
you're on my turf right and i think that
that's valid but i think what's cool
about this movie is that you don't need
to read into it
like he's
because that character is also just his
take on an archetypal western hero but
in 2022 like a grumpy pants like what
would the tropes be of the like cowboy
hero in the western film but if it was
today and then you get that shot of him
with the smoke clearing on the horse at
the end that kind of ties it all
together so i think it it's not to
that's not a counter to what you're
saying i think it's both at the same
time which is what's cool about this
movie but realizing that it goes even uh
one step deeper because if o.j is jordan
peele then the sister kiki is key she's
key
key
or are there two halves of his and she's
like
i was
that's the least friendly reading i
think there's there's also that she's
just successful partnership she's the
side of him that's more compelled to do
things that are that are pop culture
friendly
like
well yeah it's like outcast like there
are two people who work well together
but obviously they come from different
spectrums you should listen to outcasts
i am very old yeah that is they think
they're kids they know three stacks
please do not know three steps the kids
know about it they know hey
together with the help of gen z milhouse
paws
pilot cw i had i had uh the original
line there was turn their ranch into
pink sauce yeah
and you changed it to ketchup i'm just
curiou i'm not uh without expressing it
opinion i think it works well either way
give us a little insight into the
background of that because i thought
pink sauce was more the more
contemporary reference
somebody told me to change that it might
be it might have been
was that a legal thing no
it was like somebody didn't i think it
was our editor kevin
and we've already made a pla we made a
pink sauce joke a couple of trailers
again really okay well maybe that's
there
i i will i'm just always curious as to
the the tele the game of telephone like
how these jokes get morphed i yeah i i
definitely changed it but it was in
response to
not to throw our editor under the bus
because not everyone should be on tick
tock and know about well no it's like
that's a good moment that's a good note
of like hey i don't get what this
reference is we should make it we should
make it more universal everyone knows
ketchup i thought it was going to be
that blood look you thought the blood
looked more like ketchup which which
also would have been interesting let's
check it out let's let's roll that back
all right play the clip
take that i mean pink sauce is so yeah
it's a it's very specifically neon pink
and it's also like kind of that moment
after ufo on film before it turned out
we wrote this a few weeks ago
okay let's catch up together
anyways yeah keep going i was just
curious booked apart on the cw
left me
and a man who eats an ashtray full of
cigarettes for breakfast
they'll pull off a makeshift western
film shoot deadlier than alec baldwin on
a budget
shutter as jordan peel ranches up the
tension so slowly the fake outs are
scarier than the actual monster
that was the creepiest scene i actually
think i think the the gordy scene is the
scariest thing jordan peele's ever made
like in any of the three movies i don't
think i've ever been as unsettled as i
was when the kid is under the table and
even though you know it's a
flashback he's fine yeah like he he
opens his own cheesy amusement park but
yeah yeah that that scene is it's so
intense and he's really patient with it
and uh the the the monkey performing the
motion capture on the monkeys really
good yeah i mean it's the mark of a good
horror film than at cgi right with a guy
or the guy from the
yeah that foreign movie the square where
the guy acts like an ape and that one's
yeah freaks out all the people eating
it's that same guy doing mocap he's gory
nice and he's great he's very believably
chimp-like right and you know like it's
it's obviously good in general to not uh
use real animals
like that especially when you have to
train them to beat someone to death
right right right right right right look
rr just a bunch of like and i was like
yes tiger eat that man's face yeah and
especially in this in this movie where
those are fake right yeah they're all
fake yeah that's okay no that's why it's
good to use cgi every animal in rrr is
totally fit including the oxen i'm not
sure if you caught that part they let
you know right away don't
mean especially in this movie where the
theme is you know the exploitation of
exploitation like i don't think you
could use real animals except the horses
the horses right yeah all right keep
going
to the film it's a cloud there
doesn't move exactly and that cloud has
been right there at least since i set
the cameras up i'll probably be looking
at the same damn cloud that we take over
the last six months that cloud i move
the god damage
tons of wind shots that are only scary
if you've never seen the happening
any wind-related horror movie is going
to get this comparison
is scarier than what you do
especially when your creature looks like
well the fries that close down in
burbank or in its final form squidward
having a maternity shoot
will someone please feed me a horse i'm
angry
stephen caught a break in 2015.
now it's payback time he's a child actor
who watched his co-stars get beaten to
death by a chimpanzee and that's still
not his worst experience in front of a
live audience
in this subplot that explores the
predatory nature of hollywood and how
most of us are so emotionally stunted we
can only process trauma through old snl
references daryl hammond anna gasteyer
cherio terry scott wolfe is the host
he's me
but of course the star of the sketch is
chris goddamn katana
i guess his business really does mess
you up
not schwing
uh pause yeah i love the uh i love the
snl name drops and then like that uh oj
got his start on the scorpion king yeah
yes and he had like the scorpion king
crew sweatshirt
i i guess
it's sad because i'm now feeling
nostalgia for a terrible period of time
which was the early 2000s but i guess
we've hit that i mean it won't come oh
yeah but i think that like it's such a
good show like that's what jordan field
does so well the details are right like
the scorpion is such a perfect choice
for what crew sweatshirt he should be
wearing because it is like like so much
of the idea is
when you work on a film
the experience has nothing to do with
the final film yeah so scorpion king is
a movie we all and the public are like
that we don't remember it that well it
was a blip on the culture radar
significant mostly for being like the
rocks sort of arrival on a weird
scorpion body right uh well no that was
the mummy returns then the scorpion king
was the movie that followed up where we
followed this is not the
this is not the story of the scorpion
king the king this is the real person
who inspired this it's like a light year
yeah it's a light year
uh but but for for him that was a
pivotal career and family moment so it
really means something to him like it's
such a great choice what a random but
not random movie yeah and that is like a
great ebay hole to fall down if you want
like some yeah uh crew merch yeah i bet
we could get like a nice scorpion king
hoodie like i have a i have a shirt from
sour grapes that larry did because i
interviewed larry david when that movie
came out and they gave me that shirt
uh and it was just like a really
memorable thing so that's not a
memorable movie but it is for me because
i had that experience oh god yeah no
like when i did um i did uh junket for
the lion king live action they gave us
like this like lion king like little
simba toy that's like this animatronic
where it's like you put the thing up to
him it's like i just can't wait to be
king and like little ears that's the
thing simba says that is the thing that
is a thing
maybe not the simba that you remember
but uh simba and that's what
[Laughter]
oh i love grubs or like whatever yeah
whatever
all right keep going i'm gonna buy some
more of that stuff
so gays in awe and a master of the craft
absolutely flexing on the audience as
jordan peele layers and jokes images and
references that will only really hit
when you watch multiple times keep our
heads up
on this one adds little character
details in the background like angel
mining crypto in his bedroom the dude
even snuck in an akira slide
nice okay look i don't have a joke here
or anything i just think he's great now
do the thing where people say the movie
title out loud that's funny
no
no no
no no no
starring
payback horsemen scream queens oscar
baiting literally
jupiter ascending
alien versus redditer
they don't live
satino morph by curious i hate every
eight by c from chimpan a to champort e
and i see what you did there hey hey
what are we doing hey hey hey hey the
little guys with the big eyes
yeah it's a big guy this guy
they sleep
they so silly
was gordy's home in nickelodeon sitcom
cause then the weird foot stuff makes a
whole lot more sense
yeah so uh if you don't know what we're
talking about there's some weird
nickelodeon producer with a foot fetish
dan schneider right
dan something allegedly allegedly
allegedly parody parody
there's a bunch of weird foot stuff and
all those old nickelodeon sitcoms if you
go looking for it um you don't have to
you don't have to we just told you all
you need honestly don't
uh yeah uh there's lots more to say but
at this point i will pause to say thank
you for watching and check out our
twitch channel uh twitch.tv fandom
because we got some cool stuff coming up
thursday this thursday does this come
out today ryan yeah okay great uh yeah
this thursday uh
there is a uh stream on the capcom
tokyo game show presentation and get a
new street fighter that'd be cool uh the
fandom game club continues with call of
the sea chapters three and four at three
p.m so if you play chapters one and two
right now you'll be uh you'll be all
synced up if you hear the sea calling
you yeah
and then friday oh a street fighter
event hey hey 8 a.m i love that dust off
my sticks
um
my fingers used to be so fast that's
first and then um at 11
we will continue our rings of power
watch along uh see how those rings go
and i haven't seen a single episode yet
oh no they're great it's great i really
am enjoying it all right well i'm i'm a
i'm a throne's loyalist again i'm back
back in westeros back in baby yeah you
don't have to pick you can enjoy you can
enjoy westeros and middle earth they're
just both too woke for me
that's true they both for some reason
they're both allowing non-whites in
black elves like
impossible or a black sheriff
mermaids though that's where i draw the
line no
because they're real
uh yes fandom race science is not going
to be uh it's our new show fandom race
science it's
i will not be on there yeah so
we just got a lot of those ceramic uh
heads and we'll be measuring those tongs
there's no shape of the human syndicates
um these aren't headphones
all right let's let's go on to um back
to nope uh let's watch some outtakes if
we have those ready
starring
dread hampton
black mirror outer space
kiki grip angela that's it i hate to say
it i hope i don't sound ridiculous i
don't know who this man is
roger sneakins
cinematographer
so invincible now are you
fed lasso
everything sucking up milhouse
crowd the other thing
one-eyed one mouth-flying roger deacon's
eater billowy gene is not my lover
apes together wrong
love craft country
haywood just sucked me
[Music]
[Laughter]
proud of myself
horsing around
all right because their last name is
haywood
haywood
triple h haywood hollywood horses yeah
something like that um all right good
times so uh y'all have some questions
we've got answers a nigerian medic
writes one of the underlying themes
pointed out the video is how hollywood
can chew people up and spit them out and
leave people who played a big part in
productions forgotten or uncredited true
yes can you all name a time you learned
about someone who was a big part of a
movie or tv show you love but seems
largely uncredited
so like someone who just like i guess an
under the line
well i think i think the star wars films
are filled with great examples of people
who were massive contributors to their
success but then aren't included
necessarily in the
the legend i mean marsha lucas is a name
that gets knocked around a lot and lee
bracknell and there's there's a lot
there's a lot of those kinds of kinds of
names uh
that are you know sort of like very
significant in the in the development of
that project that never that got kind of
left out along the way totally i mean i
think every
below the line person is largely
uncredited and no they're
credited but i mean like as far as uh
their contributions go unrecognized
outside of people within the industry
and you know what that's
not
it's fine as long as they're getting
paid frankly as long as you're getting
like good uh union representation and a
paycheck like
you're not being a key grip for the fame
you kind of know what you're signing up
for yeah yeah it's it's a
it's honest work and there's nothing
wrong with that you don't uh i mean
every editor literally every editor ever
um you do not understand
how much an editor can influence how
good or bad a project is because they
can take absolute garbage and you watch
it it's like oh that's great and then
you go back and you're like how did you
make that yeah like like thelma
schoonmaker is often left out of the
discussion about scorsese films and like
she's in some ways the author like he's
on set being like okay you know set the
camera here we're gonna shoot this there
but then she's taking all that footage
that he shoots and taking making it into
a story and then scorsese films
especially if you think about like
goodfellas or casino you're jumping
around through time and space and all
this stuff she's putting those segments
together yep yeah um and also on the
writing side there's usually like six
uncredited writers on everything oh sure
who have done passes to to kind of tweak
things here and there and add jokes and
stuff like that but
you know uh you want to come and do a
punch-up pass yeah i don't know how much
yeah they get paid um all right so drew
wobster writes a lot of people believe
knope stood for not of planet earth and
many characters in the film especially
jupe and his family seem convinced jean
jacket is from outer space however we
never get any actual confirmation that
jean jacket's an extraterrestrial do you
think it's an alien being or a
long-dormant undiscovered creature from
our planet
um i don't know but i will say black
people say nope a lot
i'm sorry like if you look well and so i
don't want to be like like i i
understand like what people were and i'm
not saying that that's not real i'm just
saying we say nope a lot in the same way
that if you text me something i might
respond with welp instead of well yeah
well so
he's got a history now of enjoying
declarative statements as titles because
it would be the second one get out get
out nope yeah well i was like a pronoun
but like yeah get out and then nope are
like punchy statements as titles i feel
like that makes sense without the
acronym i do think it's probably
not from earth though just because we
don't like there's never been another
observed case of one well there was also
that that discussion of um uh what the
new ufo
acronym uav yeah uap yeah um so maybe it
could be uh i mean you could use three
that is there they think it's from outer
space it might not be but i it just
seems like
it's something that got lost from
somewhere else
i think it's it's terrestrial i think it
is something that was like unearthed
from that valley because that kind of
just fits to me the central metaphor of
like this is hollywood and it's a
predator like that it's something that
this is its territory it's like hunting
grounds is they're in southern
california they're outside of los
angeles and it's like it just kind of
this primordial thing that was there
before them and is like this is my turf
and you can't right well what's great is
that uh we know that
you just eat just give it a balloon
give it a blue give it a spikey baby
don't look at it that's all you got to
do yeah
uh okay lingard singhar says i've had
this question for weeks please take it
ryan
i hated jurassic world dominion correct
how would the veloci pastor have fixed
it what's the philosophy oh there's one
of those direct to vod like you know
with purposefully cheesy kind of b-movie
where it's like a it's a guy who's uh
he's a pastor and then i think he gets
turned i haven't seen it he gets turned
into a raptor is that what happens nice
or he fights raptors i don't know
i don't i don't usually i feel like the
best b movies are the ones that they're
not they're not perfect like they're
accidentally bad or they're not like
yeah hey let's make a yes
it's a pretty funny um what is that a
portmanteau yeah neologism one of those
things where you take two words and all
right i'll
the the pop the plot follows pastor doug
jones who becomes infected by an
artifact resulting in him turning into a
velociraptor when he becomes angry there
you go i mean it wasn't like me when i
mean is it a christian film because i
feel like that would really smell spicy
comedy horror comedy horror okay but
like if i i i find religious films are
usually pretty pretty underwhelming uh
but if they were to kind of embrace that
side of things yeah is that sacrilegious
to have a velociraptor pastor i don't
know
is there that museum where like jesus is
on top of like a wrote a dinosaur right
yeah yeah yeah
we all saw it
i mean
the the evangelical christians do
believe that humans and dinosaurs
co-existed correct like they yeah so
take it literally on the ark on the ark
together raptors and humans why couldn't
they preach the good words yeah maybe
there could have been a
a raptor who uh was enlightened um two
two questions coming up that are kind of
similar from alm moisture uh 210 voice
m-o-s-i-c-e alabama mo cice
uh and also uh daisu saikoro are both
pretty much asking uh what would you
like to see jordan peel do next
something that's a bit more typical
uh wha
moishe's
cj's question was what combo film genres
do you want him to see uh next and
daisu's is what would you like to see
jordan peele do next honestly i like
when he surprises me
like i just like being surprised
whatever it is i hope it's something
that's like none of these like i would
love if it was literally the next thing
he did was a version of an action movie
with like a little bit of like suspense
and like horror in it like i would love
if he did like a version of it it
wouldn't be aliens because he just did
an alien movie but like a version of
that kind of movie i would be very
interested because again i like when
people don't put themselves in a box
spielberg has done a million different
kinds of a million different movies i
don't think his next movie would be
something like an are we there yet um
i'd watch it but i don't think it would
be something like that
but um maybe the fablemans are going to
go on a wacky road trip at some point
you don't know
that's true we don't know i would watch
that i wouldn't
i think yeah i want him to keep making
obviously what he wants to make and no
not a uh
ip thing like i don't want him to make
uh gargoyles they're people are talking
about oh he should go to do gargoyle
he's mused about bringing back gargoyles
like okay he can produce it he can like
yeah and whatever but uh please like
again there's four people who are
allowed to make original movies right
yes please let's not keep taking them
away um let him let him cook uh so yeah
and i think it seems like what he wants
to make is social commentary creepy
films and if he just made though if you
made
20 of those and that was it i think we'd
i think that'd be fantastic he's got
that one he's got a stop-motion animated
thing coming out that he co-wrote with
uh selick the nightmare before christmas
guy and it's got a key in it as well
wendell and wild i think it's called
something like that uh so that looks
cool yeah i mean i definitely think you
know sci-fi horror he seems to have an
interest in those genres and i love
those genres so i'm perfectly happy to
have him keep making weird interesting
movies in those genres but yeah i i i
would probably go see whatever jordan
peele comes out with next uh yeah i
don't have a real don't put jordan peel
in a box i don't have a real strong case
i i i'd agree that i'm glad that he's
not jumping at the opportunity because
i'm sure he's he's got every opportunity
he's had every phone call so i i'm glad
that he hasn't been seduced into i'm
gonna do a star wars transfer farmers
right it's yours jordan yeah literally
x-men literally any of those properties
i feel like he could get on the horn and
be like i'm gonna do superman they'd be
like okay great right send us a script
all right and we'll close with this
aj rod's ass i don't know if danielle's
gonna be on the episode but if she is
what are your thoughts on the punk elite
situation in aew right now and why is cm
punk such a bung hole i don't know what
i need i i've actually seen him
no punk is a wrestler i'm curious for
danielle says but i actually know the
context of it oh my god uh a really
quick breakdown so essentially uh uh uh
people think it's gonna take like how
long do you think this is gonna take
no it's not even gonna be two minutes
i'm gonna make this very quick okay
because really if you want to hear my
channel in the fridge i was gonna get
one yeah oh no go get one okay go go go
go come back um but yeah so essentially
if you want to hear my full view about
it i do have a podcast you should listen
to that we dedicated half of the episode
to it
but essentially what happened was that
there is a dude who is known for being a
jerk in various different um
wrestling places he did a very jerky
thing at a um a medium scrub yeah
um at a media scrum where he made it
about him and he obviously like wanted
to vent about the people who run the
company and then afterwards some of them
went into the shared locker room along
with their hr like or along with their
like head of talent relations and their
um
uh lawyer and uh there was a huge fight
that broke out now everyone's suspended
and no one knows going on and it is
insane because it's actually real
nice
theoretically
yeah if you want to
like
hear my actual thoughts i do have a
podcast it's called tights and fights i
am 90 hornier on there sorry about it um
but yes go what because we listen we we
covered it extensively along with a
timeline of evens tights and fights go
subscribe wherever podcasts are sold um
thank you danielle
thank you for giving me my drink quick
and uh
next week is uh thor four we'll see you
next time
and by that i mean right after this
we'll just immediately after all right
bye-bye
so they've already seen thor oh whatever
well should we tease the next yeah this
is like a pre-taped live call-in show
what are we doing now
if you want to talk about pets pets call
last week
now we're talking about crime in america
thor 4. see you next time
[Music]
you